maybe this is the drama that the people
wanted hey Carl as you said he's a
streamer first content first and we are
going to have drama now wow Danny I mean
I can't believe it I'm shocked it was
it's so funny because like that that
script was supposed to go very
differently we were supposed to have
international Master Libby Rosman talk
about recruiting Hikaru celebrate
hikaru's first Victory here and instead
the gloves came absolutely off the
wheels came off wow and look at her she
is jubilant here she was trying not to
celebrate but you could tell that this
may be the happiest moment of her chest
life she's a very strong player but she
just took down Hikaru Nakamura there it
is they're the smile